- [Instructor] Consider
the density curve below
and this density curve doesn't look like
the ones we typically see
that are a little bit curvier,
but this is a little easier for us
to work with and figure out areas.
So they ask us to find the percent
of the area under the density curve
where x is more than two.
So what area represents
when x is more than two?
This is when x is equal to two.
So they're talking about
this area right over here.
And so we need to figure out the percent
of the total area under the curve
that this blue area actually represents.
So first let's find the total
area under the density curve.
The density only has area,
the density curve only has area
from x equals one to x equals three.
So it does amount to finding the area
of this larger trapezoid.
Let me highlight this trapezoid in red.
So we want to find the area of
this trapezoid right over here.
And then that should be equal to one
because all density curves have
an area of one under the total curve.
So let's first verify that.
There's a couple of
ways to think about it.
We could split it up into two shapes
or you could just use the formula
for an area of a trapezoid.
In fact let's use the formula
The formula for an area of a trapezoid
is you would take the average of,
you would take the average of this length.
Let me do that in another color.
This length and this length
and then multiply that times the base.
So the average of this
length and this length,
let's see this is 0.25.
0.25
plus this height,
0.75,
divided by two.
So that's the average of those two sides
times the base,
times this right over here which is two.
And so this is going to
give us as it should have,
0.25 plus 0.75 which is equal to one.
So the area under the
entire density curve is one
which we need to be true for
this to be a density curve.
Now let's think about what
percentage of that area
is represented in blue right over here.
Well we could do the same thing.
We could say all right,
this is a trapezoid.
We want to take the average of this side
and this side and multiply
it times the base.
So this side is 0.5 high.
0.5
plus 0.75,
0.75 high,
and we're going to take
the average of that
divided by two times the base.
Well the base going from two to three
is only equal to,
is equal to one.
So times one.
And so this is going to give us 1.25,
1.25
over two.
And what is that going to be equal to?
Well that would be the same
thing as zero point what?
Let's see 0.625.
Did I do that right, Yep.
If I multiply two times
this, I would get 1.25.
So the percent of the area
under the density curve
where x is more than two,
this is the decimal expression of it.
If we wanted to write it as a percent,
it would Be 62.5%
Let's do another example.
Consider the density curve below.
All right we have another one of these
somewhat angular density curves.
Find the percent of the
area under the density curve
where x is more than three.
So we're talking about, let's see,
this is where x is equal to three,
x is more than three,
we're talking about this
entire area right over here.
Well this is actually
somewhat straightforward
because if we're saying the area
where x is more than three,
that's the entire area
under the density curve.
And the entire area
under any density curve
needs to be equal to one.
Or you could say find the percent
of the area under the density curve.
Well the whole density curve
is where x is more than three.
So 100%, we don't even have
to go through the trouble
of trying to directly calculate the area.